[Music]
towering 85 meters above the norwegian
countryside
miostonit cuts a sleek shape in the
rural skyline
housing 18 stories of restaurants
apartments and hotel rooms
this modern building might seem out of
place but a deeper look reveals it
actually blends in quite well among the
forested farmlands
this is likely because miostornet is the
world's tallest wooden building
made almost entirely from the trees of
neighboring forests
until the end of the 20th century
engineers thought it was impossible to
build a wooden building
over six stories tall traditional boards
of lumber
were fairly strong against forces
parallel to the woods fiber growth
but they were vulnerable to forces
applied perpendicular to this direction
as a result wood lacked steel's tensile
strength
or concrete's compressive strength each
necessary to support tall buildings
and battle the powerful winds found at
high altitudes
but the early 1890s saw the invention of
glue laminated timber
or glulam and a century later engineers
developed
cross-laminated timber or clt
these new wooden materials start out
like all other lumber
a freshly cut log is sawed into smooth
uniform boards of wood
then in the case of clt the boards are
glued together in alternating
orientations
with each layer set at 90 degrees to its
neighbors
the resulting material benefits from
wood's structural rigidity
in every direction allowing it to mimic
the compressive strength of concrete
and bear loads up to 20 times heavier
than traditional lumber
glue lamb on the other hand glues boards
together in the same direction
forming massive beams with tensile
strength
comparable to steel glue lamb isn't as
versatile as clt but
its incredible strength along one
direction makes it superior for
load-bearing beams and columns
these engineered forms of wood could
finally compete with traditional
materials
while also bringing their own unique set
of advantages
at one-fifth the weight of concrete
building with clt
requires smaller cranes smaller
foundations and fewer construction
workers
while concrete has to undergo a
time-intensive process of casting and
curing in a mold
timber can be shaped quickly using
computer directed cutting machines
and where concrete requires certain
weather and timing conditions
to be poured on site engineered wood can
be prefabricated in a factory
creating standardized parts with clear
instructions for assembly
taken together these materials allow for
faster and quieter construction
with more biodegradable materials and
less waste
once constructed clt and glulam
buildings are also more
resilient to some natural disasters an
earthquake can crack concrete
permanently weakening an entire
structure but cracked wood panels
can be easily replaced
the same is true for fire safety as
temperatures rise
in a clt building the material's outer
layer will char
insulating the inner layers for up to
three hours this is more than enough
time to evacuate most buildings
and once the smoke is settled charred
panels can be swapped out
unlike melted steel beams but perhaps
the biggest benefits of clt and glue
lamp
are outside the construction site
building construction is responsible for
11 of annual global carbon emissions and
the production of steel
concrete iron and glass are major
contributors to that figure
timber however is a renewable resource
that can be made
carbon neutral if trees are planted to
replace those cut down
wood also has low thermal conductivity
making it easier to heat
and cool buildings with less energy
waste
despite these advantages clt requires
vastly more lumber than traditional
wooden construction
and when compared in similar quantities
neither clt
or glue lamp is as strong as steel or
concrete
even meustornet isn't made entirely of
wood
as it contains concrete slabs to
reinforce the upper floors
taken together it's unlikely that a
purely wooden structure
would be strong enough to support a
40-story building the minimum height for
a formal skyscraper
but even if only buildings under 30
stories were built from wood
it would reduce the carbon footprint of
those structures by more than 25
so no matter how tall these wooden
buildings rise each one contributes to
the health
of our concrete jungles speaking of
concrete what if cracked concrete could
fix itself
this revolutionary technology could save
resources
and lives learn what the secret
ingredient is
with this video
you